my viewers and subscribers and followers
have been asking me for some time to do
more of these personal development
videos where I talk about my own
philosophical if you want to call it
progress my formation who it is that I
really got captivated by and studied and
who's still valuable for me in the
present so one of the ones that was
quite important for me in my graduate
career was Jacques Derrida I was I was
very interested in his work and read my
way through his corpus and you know in a
fairly small department I think we had
about 15 professors in our graduate
department and something like you know
30 to 40 graduate students for a while I
was thought dairy dad and I ended up
leaving that behind so I'm doing this
video to talk about that that phase of
my my philosophical development so like
I said I I got into him in graduate
school and that's in part because
Derrida wasn't somebody who you would
get exposed to where I want to undergrad
or in the you know less formal
philosophical studies that I had been
carrying out since my my teen years
robbed you know buy books and read my
way through them and try to make some
sense out of this this discipline called
philosophy because I was interested in
how it would fit in with understanding
the world and myself in my life and
those sorts of things so it wasn't until
I got to Southern Illinois University in
2005 that I really heard much about
Derrida I'd you know I had a whole stack
of continental philosophy books given to
me there's a whole nother story to tell
about that when I was an undergrad as
part of a perk of a reading project that
I was doing helping to present and other
students work but Derrida was not one of
the thinkers in there surprisingly and
so you know
why did I get into Derrida I suppose
that you could say that that part of it
was because I came to Southern Illinois
University really interested in the
philosophy of language and when I first
got there I signed up for classes in in
you know continental philosophy but also
a lot of classes in analytic philosophy
in part because I knew that analytic
philosophy is interested in language I
knew that language is a major theme and
continental philosophy I was coming in
as somebody who is already you know
really into Nietzsche you can you know
watch the video about my Nietzschean
phase I'll put a link to it in the video
description here below and so I was
trying to you know think as much as
possible about things in in you could
say in linguistic terms and what I ended
up doing I'll come back to this in a bit
but what I ended up doing quite often
was engaging in lines of thinking or
criticism or argument in the course of
my seminars or in my conversations with
other older you know graduate students
would progressed further and had read
much more than I had I would say things
that were fair leader ideon without
having read Derrida and so you know what
did that you know what did that point
towards well these people said oh you
you know are you getting this from
Derrida you'd probably really like
Derrida you should read him sometime and
so I thought okay yeah sure I should
also mention that I was going through my
my Francophile phase as well you know my
family I'm gonna I'm adopted and and my
mother's side of the family is
french-canadian they've been here in the
States for a number of generations but
my mother grew up speaking French before
English and so I learned French and you
know it was the 90s so there was kind of
a you know French Canadian nationalism
going on it was the year of the
referendum was 95
you know the area that we we lived in
here in the Midwest at one time was part
of New France and so there was all of
that I'm gonna study French people to
stick it to the ingles as well at dari
that was all about sticking it to the
Anglos at one point or another so that
all of that was going on but I was you
know in my first I would say my first
year and a half I was primarily focused
on you know my coursework and the
reading that I was doing outside of that
was you know it was other French authors
like Louis Vuitton and Celine you know I
was you know reading and rereading
Voyager abuddin de nuit and Jacques
Bataille and people like that and you
know I was also progressing and in my
studies in German I was doing a lot of
work on Vidkun Stein for for a while as
a matter of fact I started out writing
my master's thesis on on him and because
where I wanted to steer him was was you
know in retrospect more along duranium
lines I didn't end up completing that
you can you and hear about that in my my
VidCon Stinney Enphase video as well I
also get into a door no door no I really
enjoyed because in order to adequately
read his books in in the German you
needed five languages
you know most of which I had either
under my belt or I could you know start
to get around with the Greek took a
while to come later on but so there was
all of that going on and you know I was
still super into Nietzsche getting into
arguments about Nietzsche and about
politics and language and society and at
the same time a friend of mine also
proposed that we should do a reading
group on Feridun and assessors
course in general linguistics I read the
French of course he had the English
version the translation of which I don't
remember you know which edition it was
at the time was actually quite quite bad
and you know we'd compare notes back and
forth so all this stuff is kind of
menteng in there and then I start
reading Derrida and I was really you
know quite captivated with that before I
ended up reading some of his stuff
though I managed to effectively
replicate his work although not at the
the level that that he had in my
master's thesis which was on who Cyril
and I focused on who the whorls passive
synthesis lectures which was being
translated by one of the professors at
the time I I was very interested again
in language so I was focusing on how
language develops and I was sort of
blending together who Cyril and distal
sir not realizing that Derrida had
already done it and done it much better
in speech and phenomena which was his
own very early work as well right but so
all of this is going on and then finally
I start getting into Derrida and reading
some of his his essays and I was really
captivated and why was I particularly
captivated well I think that looking
back at it it's been some time since
I've actually given this much thought
there are some things that I think
Derrida is right about and I still think
so today you know much of these are
things you can also find in other
authors and Derrida sometimes takes them
a bit too far which which then you know
doesn't nullify the original rightness
but but it's somewhat attenuates it but
I was really captivated by you know
pointing out that things like you know
his famous dictum there's nothing
outside of the text if you understand
that in terms not of well there's
nothing outside of it you know written
language or a book or something like
that but you understand it as there's
nothing that escapes the the codes the
the ways in which language you know if
you want to put it in terms of in facts
or or conditions or any of these things
are our world I think he's actually
fundamentally
right about that you know I know there's
Mystics who want to say oh there's stuff
totally beyond language well you're
talking about it right the an ineffable
is within language insofar as we're
signalling something about it we don't
have to go into all sorts of things
about that but there was there was a
part of me that was really captivated by
that and and that's the part of a person
that that's very interested in you know
deep questions that sometimes lead you
into epistemology sometimes lead you
into metaphysics sometimes lead you into
moral philosophy in dairy now these were
all connected up with each other as they
often are for for French writers it's
not for nothing that one of the flagship
journals in 20th century French
philosophy was the review did meta
physique a moral right
the review of metaphysics and moral
theory you could call it right or
however you want to translate it because
these things do interpenetrate each
other and you know I was fortunate in
that when I went to SIU it was a
pluralistic Department we still had some
of the analytics who you know wanted to
banish everybody else out of philosophy
but they were the old guard and they
were kind of dying out they had they had
you know done what they were going to do
you know decades before there were some
younger analytics who were a bit more
you know there were good scholars in
their own right but they were also
understanding of the fact that analytic
philosophy particularly of the logical
positivism type was not the be-all and
end-all we had classical American
philosophy we had some people who did
some history of philosophies
particularly early modern philosophy we
had a guy Andrew black who was great
with that who is an analytically trained
person but it would let me do more
continental historical approaches to to
the thinkers that we were studying and
then we had you know a strong cadre of
people doing continental philosophy we
had Garth Gillen who became my mentor
who did contemporary French philosophy
and Adorno we had Stephen Timon who
you know German philosophy but also
Kierkegaard Anthony Steinbach who had
recently come in who was doing a lot of
phenomenological work then we hired Kent
stickers as well who is you know sort of
split between American and and
continental but he did work on Schaller
and people like that so it was really
quite a good place to be for getting you
know a lot of background stuff but what
was even better
graduate students tend to be sort of you
know fan types right they get into HUS
role and now the whole world has to be
read through huh Cyril may apply host
role to everything or they get into
Aristotle and the Aristotle person you
know has to be the champion of Aristotle
and so the same thing happened with me
in terms of you know thinking in terms
of language and and not just dairy now
but primarily dairy doc you know you you
you test out whether what you're doing
make sense by throwing it into the mix
and and sort of contending with other
people and Derrida I think particularly
lent himself to that because his work is
intrinsically agonistic in a way that
you you can say that other philosophers
aren't necessarily doing and so you know
I was really getting into to studying
Derrida and I had to you know do it
against you you could say in a somewhat
hostile environment and I thrived at
that time on that sort of you know back
and forth and and fighting and then you
know when I went where my mom actually
went on vacation to France she brought
back several books for me and one of
them was you know they're gonna
Rheumatology right and I hadn't read it
at that point you know I just read some
some essays and people are you know
telling me oh this is the kind of thing
that you seem to be into and then I
spent about a month you know in my
office I remember doing that going
through this and being like wow
this is this is great stuff and then I
was off to the races
I should point out too that I never
really got into what we could call
middle period be read so I'm changing
the subject a little bit this is from
Dara DAWs you know early really
groundbreaking work in his career and
it's really you know it's great stuff I
think there's there's there's a lot of
points that are contestable but there's
a lot of stuff that's really quite you
know worth looking at again and and
learning from I would say that holds for
speech and phenomena for writing and
difference and then you know much much
later we get this turn that happens with
you know books like the gift of death
and the specters of marks and all that
you know turn towards religion and and
politics in a very explicit way towards
the end of dairy dad's life and I like
that stuff too although sometimes it's a
little bit too precious right but the
middle period where dairy die is you
know turn deconstruction and to
essentially his his approach to
everything and it's a cottage industry
and he had lots and lots of acolytes and
he could pretty much do whatever he
wanted in the way of deconstruction and
people would buy it I didn't really get
into too much I'd read it I'd be like I
don't think this is a valuable reading
of Plato or Hegel I get I see what he's
doing but I don't think I want to spend
my time on this so for me it's always
been you know the early period stuff I
really like the later period stuff I I
respect the middle period stuff you know
I leave that to the dur idioms who are
invested in you know making sure that
the master has you know has his pedestal
to be on I'm not that that sort of
person so you know for several years I
was using Derrida quite a lot although
you know I would
ever say that I was a purist in the
sense of thinking that Derrida
had the answers to anything you wouldn't
be a good Rhydian if you if you did
quite quite frankly and I was also you
know reading Deleuze and Foucault you
know sort of the people that are
contemporaries still continuing and
deepening my study of Nietzsche and
Hegel and you know bringing in some
other thinkers as well I got into
semiotic s--
I was reading a lot of echo we are
fortunate as well that not only did we
have a great philosophy department but
the speech comm department also had
another great thinker
Richard Lanigan who taught several
courses that I took on continental
philosophy but in terms of semiotics and
communicati so that was really quite
enjoyable
now what ended you know how did I sort
of shift out of the durian phase I would
say that there were a number of
different things that brought me out of
it at bottom I would say that the most
important thing was discovering other
authors who I thought were more valuable
you know who I enjoyed and got more out
of reading and I thought were you know
fundamentally more correct about about
matters one of those who played a very
important role for me was was the 19th
and 20th century philosopher Maurice
blown-down sometimes called the Catholic
Hegel or the French Hegel he used a a
method which he calls early on the
method of imminence and then he kind of
changes the name a little bit because it
runs into some problems with imminent
ISM you know in Catholic circles but
it's it's very similar to that of not
only phenomenology but also
deconstruction so he was doing something
effectively like der ideon
deconstruction not quite so much focused
on language per se but on you know
structures and how they fit into each
other and what their presuppositions are
and how they you know
they're you know working themselves out
in inaction he was doing that sort of
stuff back in 1893
I think Omri barracks owned arguably was
doing something similar I'll you know
I'll use sort of a joking thing is a
sort of proof of this I was in a summer
seminar with with my mentor Garth Garth
Gillan and I remember sitting in his
office we'd chosen to work on Eric's own
and I was working on the essay on the
immediate Givens of the consciousness
when I think the English translation is
time and free will but the French is
actually the essay on the immediate data
or Givens of consciousness and what
burke Derek's own is doing there is
again somewhat similar to what whose
role was doing in phenomenology and he
you know you can push his his ideas
about language in a certain way so you
can get some fairly turkey and stuff out
of it and my mentor actually kicked me
out of his office and said I don't want
to hear regurgitated Derrida out of you
come back when you have something
different to say about baritone and so
you know there was all of that I would I
would say that another thing that was
going on for me was I was getting deeper
and deeper and deeper into the study of
language and languages you know I took
Faron on Disko sirs advice to heart if
you want to study linguistics you need
to master multiple languages otherwise
you're just theorizing about stuff that
you don't understand very well and so so
I did that and the more that I did come
to understand you know indo-european
comparative linguistics and and how
things are working in Greek and you know
what was going on and you know this
transformation in German and and what
the sense of different French words
could be pushed to or all that the less
the less happy I was with somebody read
us some conclusions about things and
this is a problem also with
with other thinkers as well who like to
really play with the language a lot but
but with dairy diets it's it's almost
like an obsession with him you can't you
know he's always got to push the
envelope one thing further and he's the
guy at the party who you'd be like you
know buddy that was really cool what you
were doing up until three minutes ago
and then you crossed a line and now it's
just buffoonery or you know you're being
you're being a pain and we'd like to
continue our conversation over here
about what what we're doing without your
input anymore and so there was you know
there's a kind of conflict and sadness
that comes with that when you have an
author who you particularly like and
then you know you come to conclusions
different from them on good basis so
there was that I also you know one of
the other things that I think that
really attracted me to dairy dog was
this this whole notion that and you see
this running through what we can call
genealogical approaches to philosophy in
general going all the way back beyond
Nietzsche but but you know you know that
that whole thread is that we're gonna
sort of like unmask things we're gonna
pull the veil back and why are we doing
that we're not doing it just to like say
well everything is power and everybody's
a hypocrite and you know
bla bla bla bla we can substitute
whatever locations you want in there and
people do all the time but it was it was
rather that there was something going on
that could give way to a positive
project underlying any sort of real
critique that the sort that you find for
example in on grommet ology is a a
yearning this is very clear in dairy das
later works a yearning for something
greater something more positive let's
call it freedom or let's call it you
know friendship or whatever you want to
call it and the idea is that that you
know modern reason and it's political
structures and the ways in which even
codes and language work have choked that
down have suppressed that there's
there's something that is is there for
us as a possibility but it's not often
realized and here's the thing that
happened with me I started you know
poking around yeah you know in in my own
existence and finding all sorts of
pockets of things that looked like what
you know we were supposed to be looking
for and and fighting for and they didn't
have to do with era da or his critique I
you know I found that in significant
part in intellectual communities that
were being enriched by you know by by
religion by you know various sorts of
practices later on I would say I find
something similar in Aristotle and and
those who you know keep thinking through
his work and in in stoicism and in any
case things are not as dim as Derrida
presented them and I think this is you
can say the same thing about to lose and
Foucault and a lot of these other people
as well they they're they're too given
to discounting too much so they're like
live and it says there they're right in
what they assert they're wrong and what
they deny great phrase by the way who
did I learn that from not from reading
the line that's although I like live
minutes but I skipped over that learned
it from blown del Sol you know I have
not myself been doing an awful lot of
work or even you know quite frankly
reading of Derrida for a long time I've
only published two pieces that are
connected with Derrida one was very
early on in a journal called Minerva and
that had to focus that that focused on
his his later works I'll put a link to
it in the thing another made its way
into this book rethinking philosophy
religion it's one of the book chapters
it's been years since I've actually read
it called continental philosophy
Catholicism and the exigent exigencies
of responsibility the resources of
Maryse blown Del's works but it's
actually a piece that's about half half
way about blown L on half way about
Derrida essentially saying hey hey der
idioms cuz there were a lot of der ideon
zat this conference all that stuff you
really love about Derrida you can find
that in blown del and he did that in
part because of his grounding in in you
know a Catholic community and
intellectual tradition so things are not
quite so bad as you
the yridians who now want to recuperate
religion as a resource have presented
that so since then I haven't really done
an awful lot I've you know prescribed
Derrida as readings in in classes when I
had the opportunity to teach continental
philosophy classes which is a long time
ago now that I think about it the last
time that I assigned Derrida in a class
would have been when I was still
teaching in the prison so you know at
the latest 2008 but probably earlier
than that
I still enjoy reading him and you know
down the line I I want to go back
through the grommet ology and a few
other works very closely I might even
put together a course on it I don't know
it will we'll have to see whether its
merits my time or not but i-i've yeah
I've long had this this this desire to
write a book essentially about 20th
century continental philosophy although
I might you know sneak in some other
people who were more recent as well
saying here I'm really I wasn't sort of
you know where I stand saying well one
of this is still valuable or valid in in
the present upon retrospect it was
really cool to read it it was so much
fun in my 20s to you know to be the
person who's doing all this
cool stuff reading these books and
arguing these points but frankly a lot
of that turned out to be not quite as
solid as I thought
or as well-founded as I thought and
what's still valuable in it I think
there is still quite a bit that that is
valuable in Andheri das thought
particularly this you know attentiveness
to how you can you can always find you
know juncture points where something can
be turned or twisted and whatever is
present pretending to be like the final
answer or as he puts it presents never
and entirely provides that the notion
that there's always some injustice
concealed in the structures of justice
that we put in place I think that's
quite valid and his his ways of trying
to get at it I think make a good bit of
sense now of course Plato said that back
in his own time or had Socrates say it
it is own dialogues that any justice
that we see in this world is never fully
justice you just have to turn it around
a little bit and you'll you'll find the
injustice lurking within it but you know
sometimes these things have to be framed
in contemporary ways so that's a bit
about my my own interest in Derrida and
my time that I spent you might say
apprentice incorrectly under him of
course but but you know reading and
rereading and thinking through his works
and engaging with others about that and
a bit about why I don't you know for a
long time I don't you know fit into that
framework anymore but what I still like
about about dairy down